ces soldats russes sont jeunes à peine
adulte parfois capturé par l'armée
ukrainienne qui diffusent des vidéos
certains ne semblent absolument pas être
des professionnels aguerris en début de
semaine pourtant vladimir poutine assuré
avec force qu'aucun conscrits n'était
déployé dans cette guerre
je tiens à souligner que les construit
ne participe pas et ne participeront pas
à l'opération militaire et qu'il n'y
aura pas d'appel supplémentaire de
résultats actuels sont réservés aux
personnels militaires professionnels
dès le lendemain le ministère russe de
la défense contredisait le kremlin sans
elle malheureusement il y a eu plusieurs
cas confirmés de conscrits présent dans
des unités russes qui participent à
l'opération militaire spéciale sur le
territoire ukrainien
un certain nombre de militaires y
compris les conscrits ont été capturés
la loi russe interdit l'envoi de
conscrits au combat la présidence assure
que des procureurs militaires ont été
diligentées pour mener l enquête et
punir les officiels responsables de ces
déploiements pas moins de 260 milles
russe ferait actuellement leur service
militaire deux semaines après le début
de son offensive l'armée russe patine en
ukraine les renseignements américains
sûrs qu'ils n'ont pas réussi en 14 jours
ce qu'ils avaient prévu de faire en 48
heures un manque d'efficacité du selon
des analystes militaires aux provisions
inadaptée des unités déployées notamment
en terme d'essence ou de nourriture mais
aussi au faible moral et à
l'inexpérience de conscrits trop peu
formés